[Musique]
non
c'est pour moi oui
on fait des passes misisi
alors vous prenez 12 jurés
[Musique]
surtout
hadja c'est chez toi
je t'aime
votre mari a posé une bombe dans son
usine vous fréquentez des arabes c'est
un pays arabe je vois pas comment je
ferais autrement parce que c'est un pays
il apparaît que vous avez intégré un
groupe reliées au front de libération
nationale
[Musique]
tu caches des gens que je connais pas je
sors dans la rue la nuit
voici je veux pas pas ici je pourrai
plus me regarder en face n'importe où
ailleurs ne devienne sera foutue aussi
notre place à tous les algériens c'est
ici et sur lui pas tous ensemble c'est
foutu
je suis ici parce que je voulais qu'on
soit heureux comme une vie ensemble
votre propre pays concitoyens vous êtes
un traître terme ans et dont le procès
de votre mari est une mascarade il a tué
personne alors il faut faire savoir son
histoire mais tu as fait quoi là tu t'es
battu est pas l ont pas ce que tu t'es
battu tu comprends ça regardez d'orgueil
plus en tant qu une traite comme des
chiens
franchir
[Musique]